SCARE ME.
I'M NOT JUST SAYING THAT I
WATCH THIS STUFF EVERY DAY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
SMART ANALYSIS AS ALWAYS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE BEAUTY OF BEING A
LIBERAL POLITICAL ANALYST IN
2018 IS, IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
NO MATTER WHAT THE ISSUE IS,
OR THE CONCERN MIGHT BE,
IT'S THE SAFE BET THAT YOU
TIE IT DIRECTLY TO TRUMP.
NO MATTER WHAT, HURRICANES,
HIGHER GAS PRICES.
THE ONGOING WAR OR FAMINE.
EVEN ROSEANNE BARR'S TWITTER
FEED, ALL OF THEM ARE ABOUT
TRUMP.
WATCH THIS AS COLLEGE
PROFESSOR AND PROFESSIONAL
SHAKE DOWN ARTIST MICHAEL
ERIC DYSON SHOW US HOW IT'S
DONE.
THIS IS MSNBC LAST NIGHT.
>> WE HAVE A BIGOTED CHIEF
AND RACIST IN RESIDENCE.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
HE HAS UNLEASHED SOME OF THE
MOST HORRENDOUS VIEWPOINTS,
BIGOTRIES AND RACISM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
HE HAS LEGITIMATED THEM,
VALIDATED THEM.
HE SAID LOOK, IT'S OKAY.
COME OUT THE CLOSET.
COME OUT AND SPEAK
STRAIGHTFORWARDLY AND TELL
THE WORLD WHAT YOU BELIEVE.
>> Tucker: WE LOWER OUR
STANDARDS.
I KNOW WE ALL HATE TRUMP.
BUT SO STUPID.
NOT STUPID IS MARK STEYN WHO
JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
I FEEL LIKE -- YOU KNOW, I
DON'T WANT TO OVERSTATE AND
I DON'T WANT TO BE
HISTORICAL
HYSTORICAL
HYSTERICAL LIKE THEY ARE.
THEY ARE MELTING DOWN IT
LOOKS LIKE TO ME.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
ON, TUCKER.
I MEAN, WE LIVE IN A
COARSENED CULTURE.
AND EVERYBODY HAS SAID THAT.
I THINK ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY SAMANTHA BEE, FOR
EXAMPLE, USED THE C-WORD IS
THAT THE F-WORD HAS BEEN
DRAINED OF ITS POWER.
IT WAS -- WHEN I BELIEVE IT
WAS KEN KINAN WHO FIRST SAID
THE F WORD ON THE TV IN THE
BBC BACK IN THE 1960'S, THE
IRISH PLAYWRIGHT IT H. DONE
IT A COUPLE YEARS BEFORE.
HE WAS SO DRUNK NOBODY
UNDERSTOOD THAT WAS THE
WORD.
KEN KINAN GOT THE CREDIT FOR
IT ON THE BBC.
AND THAT WORD HAS SO LOST
ITS FORCE IN PART BECAUSE
IT'S NOW SAID ROUTINELY ON
FAMILY SHOWS THAT THEY HAVE
HAD TO MOVE TO -- SAMANTHA
BEE HAD TO MOVE TO THE
C-WORD.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING IS
THAT THE CROWD WENT
DELIRIOUSLY WILD ABOUT IT.
THERE IS NO JOKE THERE.
THERE IS NO INSIGHT THERE.
THERE IS NO PARTICULAR POINT
THERE.
BUT THE FACT THAT SHE SAID
THE C-WORD HAS THE -- WELL,
WE REALLY GOT OUR VALUE FOR
MONEY.
IF WE HAD BEEN HERE 120
YEARS AGO.
WE WOULD HAVE WANTED TO SEE
A TRAPEZE ARTIST OR A TAP
DANCER OR IRISH TENOR.
TODAY WE ARE HAPPY TO GO IN
A THEATER AND CHEER
DELIRIOUSLY WHEN SOMEBODY
SAYS THE C-WORD.
THAT'S ACTUALLY SOMETHING
THAT IF ANYONE DIGS THAT
CLIP OUT IN SEVERAL DECADES,
THEY WILL BE INTERESTED TO
LOOK AT, I THINK.
>> Tucker: IT IS LOOK LIKE
AT OLD PICTURES FROM THE
REVOLUTION IN CHINA CHILDREN
WITH LITTLE RED BOOKS AND
SALUTING ALL THIS NONSENSE.
HOW COULD A HUGE GROUP OF
PEOPLE GO SIMULTANEOUSLY
INSANE?
IT'S MASS TIS HAIR I CAN'T.
IT'S A HUMAN THING.
WHAT IN THE END IS THE
EFFECTIVENESS.
DO NORMAL PEOPLE LOOK ON AND
SAY SAMANTHA BEE HAS GOT TO
BE KATHY GRIFFIN TWO.
TWO OF THE UNHAPPIEST PEOPLE
IN AMERICA I DON'T WANT
ANYTHING THEY ARE SELLING.
OR DO THEY SAY WOW, SIGN ME
UP FOR WHATEVER SHE HAS GOT?
>> NO, I THINK THAT YOU ARE
TRITE DETECT A CERTAIN
JOYLESSNESS IN IT.
I THINK THERE IS ALSO A
LOGIC THOUGH.
WE HAVE TWO INCOT AT THAT
TIME TILLABLE TRACKS.
ON THE ONE HAND HAVE YOU
THIS GENERAL COARSENING F
WORD, C WORD, F WORD.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND HAVE
YOU EVERMORE PROTECTED
CLASSES OF PEOPLE.
SAY ANYTHING ABOUT BECAUSE
THEY ARE BLACK, THEY ARE
GAY, THEY ARE MUSLIM, THEY
ARE TRANSGENDER, WHATEVER IS
NEXT DOWN THE PIKE.
WHICH MEEPTION THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH TRUMP OR WHO
ARE RELIGIOUS CONSERVATIVES
OR WHO ARE WHATEVER.
IT'S A VERY NAY ROW SLIVER
OF PEOPLE CAN YOU UNLEASH
THE BLIZZARD MUCH FNC WORDS
ON.
THAT'S THE CONTRADICTION.
AS WE HAVE TALKED BEFORE B.
BEFORE, TUCKER, IT'S
ACTUALLY KILLING COMEDY.
THE FANTASTIC THING ABOUT
THIS SCHOLARSHIP THAT IT IS
A SUPPOSED COMEDY SHOW.
IT'S GOT WRITERS AS TAMMY
WAS SAYING.
IT'S PRETAPED.
IT'S ALL CAREFULLY EDITED.
BUT THERE ACTUALLY ISN'T A
JOKE IN THERE UNDER NEATH.
THERE IS JUST THE WORD.
>> Tucker: I KNOW IT WAS
ONLY A COUPLE YEARS AGO
REMIND ME WHY NTSB FIRED
BILLY BUSH.
HE LAUGHED AT A JOKE THAT
WAS LESS VULGAR THAN THIS
AND HE GOT FIRED AND THEY
DESTROYED HIS LIFE BECAUSE,
WHY?
DO YOU REMEMBER?
I DON'T REMEMBER.
THAT'S THE INJUSTICE HERE.
ROSEANNE WHO I DON'T THINK
IS ANY KIND OF CONSERVATIVE.
I HAVE NEVER SAID THAT BUT
ROSEANNE HAS HAD 40 YEARS OF
WORK VAPORIZED OVER HER
TWEET.
AND UNLIKE SAMANTHA BEE, SHE
IS ACTUALLY FUNNY AND SHE
WAS FUNNY IN A LEFTY WAY.
SHE HAD LESBIAN KISSES 30
YEARS AGO.
BUT HER LESBIAN KISS HAS
BEEN VAPORIZED WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE BECAUSE SHE
HAPPEN -- SHE IS PERCEIVED
AS SUPPORTING TRUMP.
THAT DOUBLE STANDARD IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> Tucker: IT'S BEEN
SCRUBBED FROM DIGITAL.
YOU CAN'T -- IT'S LIKE THE
DUKES OF HAZARD, YOU CAN'T